rất là cuộc chiến iroan chứ có hối két,
căng thẳng dưới xa reng và thổ nghĩ kỳ đăng lao thẳng thì
ăn cả ra tìm cách tiếp lập quyền lực trong bối cảnh
bất oon của khu vực chung đồng, à đập.
Ngày hai bà thẳng tắm, tờ đất tham sợp
e xa reng dẫn một số mùn tìm tiếp lỗi xa reng,
đã thung bà với Mỹ rằng thổ nghĩ kỳ đăng có kỳ hoặc
thiết là phê thống phòng không tạc cảnh cứ không quận ABU đu hủ ở
tế bắc xíri, mà lực lượng phòng về xa reng IDDF đã tấn công tình
trước.
Tên á viết bà y tỏ lòng ngại với Washington rằng việc
ăn cả ra tích lập phép thống phòng không tạc ABU đu hủ.
Tì sẽ ăn hơn biểu thế không quân của Xa reng trong khu vực
và thay đổi cán tân quyền lực.